And we also had the good fortune of having the support of the health and. Building surveyor. For terrain is shot.
Through an issue i was later moved into the city of liz mill.
But that time the help in building survey was one wily doctoring. And while he was quite fascinated with.
What was going on in the preparation vista will bend over backwards to help us so he really made it easy for us.
So we deliver the shah negotiations also had this sort of measure of quality.
And for the resilience to it was really special time and.
One of the landowners cool day smith was very helpful to us
and dave had a property that i joined one of the sights of the festival which we leased and.
The boundary was the creek morgan creek. And dave took to riding his horse.
Down to the creek to inspect the boundary and see how things were developing there.
And of course one of the mums was there was a lot of naked swimming in the creek and. David course. We ask. We can.
You know.
Give her a ride in the horse and he'd stand there and these naked women would take his horse up the creek
and fight lady godiva and it was jest magically that beautiful women.
You know in good will select and say you know it's just a good feeling.
That was like we are many is to establish the vibe of the festival how we wanted the festival to be.
Early on the meeting with the message we were completely taken by the mcluhan.
Idea that we have to demonstrate in everything we did. And. And it was difficult at the same time.
More and more people arrived in him than. Under the aegis of the festival. What we discovered was that.
Less work was being done and the more people we were feeding in the less. It was being done the go.
Progress on the side getting the toilets and things made was going very slowly
and exhausting the people who were doing it. And meanwhile. There was a lot of it lying around in the street.
So i will say this difficult job of motivating people. And. It came to a head for me.
And it was an issue that's been that has dogged newman ever since like the role of gate keeping.
How do you how to get people to agree on standards of behavior when everything is free. You know that and.
It was personified for me in the arrival of a particular woman who was which. Right and i.
I do not use this word lightly. She had been brought to town by a guy who was willing in the occult.
And he he had a house a property ever in the coast. Byron bay way.
And this woman is obviously too much and he just up and said well taken him another look after your name
and so he literally drove up and pushed around the can. And lifted them. She was dressed.
She used to wear a very short skirt. In one hand she clutched at a dirty rag doll. Much. Much handled ragdoll.
She would have been made forty for the hard to say. Face blown up by excessive consumption of alcohol.
And in the other hand she would clasp a bottle. And say. And.
She was a woman of some power parent she'd been an actress and she her timing was immaculate.
She knew what to say and how to say it in a way that really shocked people. Went to the rich.
And it wasn't too long before she was thrown out of the newman pub.
And the story is that to the lawyers in the newman pub. Who of course.
Fascinated by who these women hang around i mean this is. This is the town that was. Didn't have too many young women.
Suddenly. Indicted with single women.
He is he they were staring at her and she's just tennis to me what you want to fuck with so.
Confronting them with the truth. So they checked around.
But that didn't stop her from getting alcohol so she arranged for other people to buy. Who had booze.
And she would lie in the street with the. Dress up around the crotch. Drunk in abusing people as they were passed.
Now for me this was a crisis. You know in our community liaison process quite apart from sitting example.
Still expecting to be fed by the festival.
You know to encourage people not to work and she had a whole following around. You know. If we don't have one.
You know this.
It's all just happening man it's all just happening in the food is just happening and you're just happening and.
It was just him he shut up and leave us alone. So what happened.
You know i try to nile and say well we can't feed you and she's.
Fixed me with the beady eyes and let me know that i was the double whammy tonight.
I was suffering from overwork at that time. We were working seven and seven day weeks and.
You know ten hour days to this guy. We had to reinvent the. The sabbath. Give us a wrist you know it was.
Everything was up for invention at this time we discovered the sabbath was a very good idea to take a day off every
seven days. And i was struck and i remember being walked around the house who were standing by my friends you know.
And i was totally obsessed want to be going to do with. This and grime it's only one small problem. You know.
Think of all the good things that have you remember all was good but it was like ok. I just had a print of mine.
So it was a kind of. My fix. First hexing right. And. The whole thing about the agrarian space to with that.
From the point of view of a university student. Studying sociology we had lots of wonderful ideas.
The practice of being on the street implementing those ideas with the now the total reality of you dealing with people
that didn't have the ideas necessarily.
Had lots of other wedding ideas that didn't associate of sure the university was like a privileged environment to
develop ideas there were there were fences around i'd forgotten about the fences
and other fences you had did so many years of school
and pass exams all that kind of stuff before you were allowed to join the conversation. I'd forgotten about that.
And i discovered this whole other reality world community where all kinds of people turned up
and you had to deal with all kinds of energy. So that was my first confrontation with a pixie.
And we managed to solve that one by going around to people asking for a you know.
Respect was going on respect for the locals and everyone who came out about the festival.
Development don't talk to this woman. And suggest that she not the soffits to the townspeople.
And it worked what happened was that. She changed her name to enter jellicoe.
And disappeared off the street she went and lived by the time we'd secured the release on the festival site
and she went and lived on the rest of the site and ceased to be an education to the. The festival production.
So there were the invention or the other adventurous type.
People have tell you another story bellenger like it was that. There was a band over in coaching kogan.
At the time and they represented. The the. The settlers who had settled in the main i'm barely. We going to maine.
In search of the property.
But we've been told clearly by some of the settlers they didn't want to know about any festival happening in the valley
thank you very much.
They are lived very quietly on they are growing they die very quietly thank you very much and didn't want to publicly.
But nevertheless we've had a lot of supporters who liked the idea of the festival
and cogan offered to give us a free concert. And i travel all the way from more to glamorous. The back roads.
To give this concert. Now. There was a the debate about the quality and structure was ongoing.
I mean how do you run this organized everything was up for grabs and we've had previous conversation about this where.
You know there'd be no division between performer and audience. Like anyone could be a performer and.
It happened this night that. This. This woman i spoke of before the which. Decided that she wanted to sing too.
And when the band sort of hostile rough and said no we worked in a gig thinking. We don't need any help.
She got up on stage and wander around a bit and people ignored her until she got one of the microphone leads
and against drinking the drama. Stopped me. Walked off. She set down the drum. And started playing a self you know.
Do you think your eyes and anyway. Talk about hicks like.
They came to nimbin in three counties
and on the way back from it they had a three calculation they ran into each other right. With this woman shit.
And another occasion i remember using the name of the who were a great debate. Erupted about.
Structure and about who had the right to be on stage as a performer and who hadn't and. Escorted by.
All the audience got up and got on the stage right. Everyone is a performer no such was the dynamism.
Yes it was just spontaneous everyone got up and. Then we tried that for a while and that didn't work so i think.
So that's where the plates. Yes to and. Well it was mainly for the septic tank system. The public toilet.
We made and liked a sort of a festival planning day. Called people and all the people involved in producing things.
As many people to get there is possible to come for a meeting about the festival.
So we had a lot of people in town and in fact it was a mini festival in itself and nimbin is one of those.
Country towns that made a major contribution. In blood. To both wars and. One of the things i.
When i was reading about the history of nimbin there are photographs of.
Men from the tweed valley sitting on the wharf. You for people who don't know this there it's a river port.
It's up to the. The northern rivers.
And most of the towns the major towns were sort of the originally as timber towns to see the getting towns.
And as river ports. And it was the river port for the tweed. It was like the war.
Was really stacked with young men being sent off to the first world war and they had the feeling that this war.
From which they exported all the butter and.
All of the dairy produce in the team or all the produce from the the valley. Was also now.
Exporting its manpower is young men. To go on for fighting this foreign war. And they're doing this.
It's obvious to me from the reading because they are really proud of what they've achieved. The settlements.
Pullet the settlement. Of that area.
We're talking about nine hundred fourteen
or something would have been only thirty years old at that time they'd cleared the forest. Built the.
Establish a farm economy. And to build the towns and the homes in the churches.
And i had a lot to be proud for that they had brought. Western civilization the best of it. To this untamed country.
The big scrub. They can.
It was if they'd you know rush you will and they didn't they'd created this community up here and.
The prove that they are part of the empire. And this great future they sent these you.
Off to war and of course the most wanted and.
I think that's my understanding of this theory and the spirit went out of it.
And the woman more will speak a lot about guilt. More than glory. In this area. And again the second world war.
And the queerest. Festival. Acquired the the name been returned services. League club.
For five hundred dollars we were really using that as the festival office and.
When we cleaned up to move in there we discovered all the photographs of.
You know that had been reproduced of all the men from the village that it served in the second world war as well.
And we had those arranged on the wall. You know so we are quite conscious of. The war legacy.
We are still something we come and claim the photographs and put them into storing and then.
I had an inquiry a couple of years ago i lost no one knows where they are. Least we were we had them on display and.
So that the end they parade became of special significance to the nimbin people because it represented their culture
and what they were proud of him because it's they had so many strangers in town from the clearest this will always talk
about the new age in creating this new culture. They put on quite a show and. We were there to witness the parade.
And they went from the parade into the town hall for the service and sick texas and. Just at that moment.
The septic tank.
Which was much overloaded by all of this is the town blew up
and roared through duran down the hill beside the two that's in the hall. Obviously side the. The hole and.
The whole town stank of thirds that weekend. And so it was.
With us i'm like no no no no there's a lot of respect for that. But the townspeople because they match so proudly on.
It was certainly no heckling or anything like that. So we approached the festival. And of course.
The closer we got to the. The more intense it became the negotiations the work.
I'm going to post by the time we got the things. Festival johnny and i were sort of. Basket cases. Johnny along.
Lost his voice. And johnny allen is. Has a beautiful time.
And beautiful voice he could spin tiles and get people's agreement. He couldn't speak and. I couldn't he was.
I was people overload people would talk to me
and i literally could not hear what they're saying i deceive the lips moving. Nothing.
No meaning went into the brain i was that. I just had too many. So i gotta say that.
Rather time the festival began i was in no state to enjoy you know the except sleep.
And julie and i had made this pact that when the festival began we would retire. As organizers.
And that other people take care of the organization the festival and. Let me say it worked. Right.
We just literally walked out of the office and then people arose
and picked up the tools we had a daily newsletter so calling for volunteers.
But one of the major two was was to keep the toilets clean and supplied with.
Toilet paper lined out and all that kind of stuff. These were sort of holes in the ground. You need sexual toilets.
You know like. This was a great spiritual breakthrough for some people in mixed company.
But they're not all the total out there but there are some that were deliberately left as that kind of option. Anyway.
Servicing the toilet and keeping them. You things clean with a major issue and. What happened was that a woman.
Offered their services she was a labor organizer of a civil and civic. Civil construction. She. Got some. C.b. Radio.
From the state emergency service and. Had a team of people who used to work around reporting and.
She'd organize the supplies you would wonderful.
She did that for about four days then she walked out of the office and someone else picked up the task.
So that so the first of all maintenance with. Was kept on. I also we had a free press.
We had a lithographic press that used to produce. Pamphlets out the back and people. Anyone can produce a pamphlet.
And distributed. Bush video with their theory videoing the festival and reducing the first cable network.
Who we got one monitor in a shop front by the end of the festival. But they put lots of interesting.
Half inch black and white. Video was taken at the time. All when one of the phenomenal remember was that.
I remember that one of the reasons for going to name one was to get away from the authority structures. Right now.
I was so into living in them but by the time the festival. Because we dealing on foot of a personal place.
Basis with the police and being totally open with us i mean we struck a deal with the. The head of the c.i. B.
About drugs he came up to us and said. This is how old frederick slighted. The mayor of this morning he said look.
I understand there are going to be. Drugs at this festival.
I don't want to be embarrassed by the drugs at this festival so keep them off the streets. So that was a pact that.
The police wouldn't go into the fields and arrest people for drugs.
And we would make sure the drugs were in a part of the street scene.
So i was finding the police very cooperative because we had the support of matching the local policeman.
But as people arrive for the festival from the university. You know i left with the when the.
The festival began in earnest and then. The trains that. We heard all these complaints from the left wing is arriving.
Or they could see their arriving town or they could see was a policeman right. Thing.
When we actually went down to a camp of a radical group.
And this is what they told us and we thought we had them who we thought were coming to a free zone you know.
And we will be sleaze police everywhere. Thing. Police or even ball. And it was completely different vision. You know.
Thing being part of the community. Some are one of the last to say about memories of the festival.
Apart from exhaustion. Yeah. And this this this issue of authority. Arose yes.
There was an interest in the situation was that the police had gone to sleep without telling us. And arrested.
Here when you said. It was a smack case. This kind of perfect.
I wouldn't believe that smack would come to the festival but. It's makers everywhere. And. And as a ring.
The wrist the through. Through the festival.
They passed all coming up the road and it was only about twenty paces
or fifty from the most fifty meters from a sound stage.
And people just rendered the sense that agency that's a police bust. You know.
And the festival was so together as a community like people just rose as one and ran to the place the petty wakin
and liberated. The. The prisoner and. In the in the melee. A policeman's gun was still on. And this of course.
He to ruin the. We had the situation of. The media not knowing what this festival was about.
And suddenly it had a story. And it hit the afternoon dailies. In sydney. You know typical you know.
Hippies rioting and steal gun. So there was a lot of song. So it's seen that happen.
In the face of that time there's a big meeting the next day to talk about it.
And there were a whole group of people who wanted the you know.
Action taken against the police they were down on the play station like on the stuff they had the interrupt office to
fill. And there are people who are suing for peace who want the gun returned. Thing forgotten. Not the gotten that.
They go in with the intent of the fist of which was to discover a community to step in the future.
Rather than to slip back into. Antagonism and define the system in terms of opposition.
Now the issue became increasingly urgent.
Because what the police response in sydney was to send up the twenty first division which is of the tactical response
squad that. Of the times. Leads with the policeman's policeman.
And they were the two best people who bash policeman basically. And they arrived in town.
With the breath we soon became aware. To bust the fist of all.
And within sort of an hour of arriving and taking up duties in yemen.
They were busting people in the main street people who had been sitting you know the festival.
This magical place with all kinds of performance of having a street
and people would sit around in the streets of in the.
Part of the magic of the festival
and suddenly the head of the twenty first division was saying you have no more riots in the streets
and women than you would have in street if you sit down in the street to be a wrist watch it anyway.
Clear to us that something worse was happening going to come.
And so i went on the police station and demanded a meeting them. Between the. The superintendent of the police.
The regional police and the head of the twenty first division. And the people from a witness.
So a meeting was set for six pm that evening. As of thursday the twenty third division were in town.
And we thought it would be clever if we had a local person. That this would be wise so we invited dave smith.
Become the property owner i mentioned before.
Quite apart from being an old newman family dave was also the organizer for the country party. In the area.
So he invited. Dave to come to the meeting which took place in the play station. And we sat around and i remembered.
Johnny alone with his mom his punch was going to be with him and. I you with. Prison and and the minister a officer.
And dave smith talking to these two senior policeman who can only say. You have no special rights if you break the law.
We have to act on them. But this time the gonna be written by the way.
And we took them home getting it was like talking to because these guys weren't going to budge.
They were going to bust the festival this was their name and. Eventually we asked.
Di smith as dave what do you think about this. You know when we think if the police go into the fields tonight.
With the earth. It will be my him. There are lots of kids in this crown.
And you'll have stampedes and people like this. And they smith. Reply was a classic. He said. I think.
If you go into the crowds tonight if you go into the theater which will be property damage. And it just went. Klunk.
Right. Both policemen realize that if they did what they were planning to do.
They would have some local fine my saying. We told them not to on television. And so they went.
And said ok we'll review the situation tomorrow. So we stepped outside of this meeting and.
In the yeah out of the police. Splay station this by this time it was doc. Or at least sixty uniformed police.
Waiting for their instructions right. I had rusted people on from all around the place.
This mighty task force that was going to do over this deal and it was averted. Not only didn't they raid the.
The festival. Going to thier woods and risk people that night. They became the twenty first division. Sort of.
Kind of melted. As an aggressive force and they became part of the festival. And they were challenged and.
There was a sports day on the last saturday of the festival.
And they were challenged to be part of the tiger woods team. Right. Against the hippies.
Twenty first division versus the hippies. Now like they. They didn't except in the end.
However they accepted in good faith and.
And people talked in the streets and they were just another aspect of the fist of all. And talking with police.
After the fist of all there was that the party. Was i guess size. A party organized by the police themselves.
I think is that they are same club
and to say that it was by stick with the people who worked on the on the christmas day were getting together.
To have a drink before they split up and. Some of the people who worked on the festival.
When they heard about it
and went over there so they could be part of the troubadour guys who'd stablished good report with the place
and the time they're living in in the moon and played songs to them all this kind of stuff and. In the course of this.
They reported back to us that. What the police had this i would buy it were my best..
Right and the thing that amazed the most was the number of police by us. He said. There were people from the f.b.i.
People from the special school or people from. And they would come to the police station right.
To identify themselves to us because they had information
and had to be the most wacky weirdest dressed people you ever saw than the hippies for a.
For the last i don't know the police will ever tell that story. Well after the. After the fist of all.
The university students went back that. I mean. The bulk of the festival with my up of university students.
So they went back to do the courses. And back at university. These debates.
Arose these meetings were held on the campuses certainly at sydney university and university of new south wales.
After name and what. Right.
Because people had had such a profoundly moving time that they've been touched in so many ways in mind
and been open to so many possibilities that they're. Seriously examining their university career as they courses.
While my studying this is not relevant to the future
and the career what i'm going to do with himself a lot of people contemplating dropping out and the like.
So the university student went back a lot and did. Personal searches.
Other people who are high energy people who contributed to the festival also with town. This is the.
Phenomenon that the. People with these of an energy. The do is of the world. Usually have projects on the boil.
So they didn't hang around after the festival which lift.
Liftin women the flotsam and jetsam that the people who drifted into town. And.
Were looking for a place looking for someone to look after them looking for a structure to live in now that the tunnel
for cooperative had been launched by that time so there was a bit of an infrastructure coming together.
Encouraging people to hang around for two hundred dollars were going to buy this land which is thirty kilometers out of
town. But that took a long time to come when. Online it was something like six months so.
There was a kind of a disparate. Period that followed after the festival with lots of people hanging on.
I also had the job of doing sort of the clean up of the sot.
Because i was responsible for most of the borrowing and of negotiations to get the sites. And i had the.
Terrible job because people have built. Lots of. Shanties right. They built the maddest.
Sticks and twigs and bits of plastic and all this kind of stuff. Some of them quite substantial. Wood and.
There's a call from the tunnel people that we should.
Recycle as much of the timber and useful materials as possible so we were dismantling things.
But as we went in there to help again anyway
but what happened was i go to a shanty one of the shoulders of being built in.
And to be someone living in it and say look if it was over. Go to leave the site we're returning aside and.
I've got to pull this thing down myself. Don't put it on the day it would stay overnight. And leave town tomorrow.
So please leave it. As i can. And i get back the next day and.
If someone different in a lot of people live but someone different and moved in and i had exactly the same story.
I was going to totally frustrated with the track.
Because these were mushroom made as basically these are people hanging around.
Having mushroom trips which i'm quite into a mess from trip with self like i was there with a runabout.
But they were certainly not helping with the cleanup and. It was a disc coming down to a few of us.
Doing the dirty work. And i was getting more and i was exhausted again.
And i had really bad side pains i was getting very short.
And by the end of the wake of walking around with a big stick. And a box of matches. And if i found a shoulder empty.
I would move the positions out and set fire to it.
And if you want approached me complaining i would wave my stick and say the festival is over.
So so much for peace and love. So it was a very difficult job. Just that. The whole pendulum of energy. Shifted.
After the festival. So all the good energy. Went off. To do something. And all the people who were hanging around.
Writing things to be done for them. Remained on. Not all of them. I mean. But a substantial number.
I remember for example before i closed up the office. Of one of the guys coming.
And when we come out aquarius buy me a toothbrush. Career is this just lost a lot of money on this festival.
I think we lost something like twenty thousand dollars or something and.
When i have a budget but with us until i'm not in the business of blueing. Or hippies with toothbrushes.
That was the kind of attitude. So. Just like. I just got to just comment that the tide went out. We went from this.
Ecstatic high together.
To desperados in the straits wondering what was going to happen
and i had no dollar i think to support them so they were really clean.
There were a number of houses that people had rented before the festival which became so much for people to leave.
But that basically. The people who organizing the tunnel co-operative went down to sydney to do the organizing.
There was no structure in name and. So i moved over to. Because my partner in that.